j'avais envie de vous entendre sur ce
grand rassemblement monstre hier à
washington qui s'est fait quand même
dans le calme sans affrontements avec
les policiers mais les messageries était
assez clair comment avez vous trouvé ce
rassemblement écoutez ce rassemblement
des montres l'insistance et puis
l'urgence d'agir au sein de la société
américaine notamment un pour éradiquer
ce racisme institutionnel qui perdurait
depuis la lutte pour les droits civiques
nous sommes à 52 ans après l'assassinât
de martin luther king et les afro
américains vivent des situations
d'inégalité structurel de racisme
institutionnel persistant donc on commet
j'interprète cette vaste manifestation
en fait c'est que les gens interpelle le
pouvoir public pour qu'il y ait des
changements des changements durables
pour ramener justement cette égalité des
droits pour les afro-américains il ya
vraiment un fossé entre eux les
afro-américains leur réalité les
conditions sociales et le reste de la
population blanche
donc il ya un réel problème auquel il
faut donner des réponses des réponses
systémiques pour corriger cette
situation
le racisme vécue par les afro américains
alors le message qui est lancé
actuellement par la population
afro-américaine c'est que ce racisme
institutionnel doit cesser et il faut
des mesures des initiatives des projets
pour éradiquer tout c'est toute cette
disparité disparités socio-économiques
comme on en voit la même aventure que là
le décès la mort de georges tron a été
cette goutte qui semble faire déborder
le vase c'est que là et il ya ce
mouvement qui rendu pratiquement un
mouvement international on voit depuis
quelques jours qu'est-ce qui est
pourquoi ce cas vient de changer la
donne on dirait que oui oui d'accord
mais il faut dire que historiquement il
ya eu quand même plusieurs éléments
plusieurs événements un acquis qui ont
amené quand même la population à se
mobiliser et bien entendu ce qu'on a
assisté on a visibiliser vous voyez
cette violence policière et ça a été
outrageuse pour non seulement les afro
américains mais pour la société
américaine dans son ensemble et cela a
interpellé plusieurs pays à travers le
monde donc vous avez on a visibiliser
une violence policière une violence
institutionnelle qui perdure depuis des
décennies alors les gens les personnes
se sont sentis interpellés par cette
situation qui était exacerbée voyez
c'est une violence d'une ya pas de mots
il n'y a pas de mots pour exprimer cette
violence et c'est inacceptable pour une
société de droit comme la société
américaine vous voyez donc ça a soulevé
la colère des gens la population afro
américaine lance un message que nous
sommes des citoyens
nous voulons avoir un accès égal aux
ressources économiques culturelles
sociales
donc il faut en fait c'est les rapports
ainsi les rapports sociaux qui doivent
être plus égalitaire les rapports de
pouvoir qui sont fondamentalement
inégalitaire au sein de la société
américaine
avez vous l'impression que cette fois
pourrait être la bonne c'est à dire 7
monté aux barricades on pourrait dire
pourrait être la bonne parce que on
commence à voir depuis quelques jours
des changements de comportement chez les
policiers américains chez les corps
policiers qu'ils revoient leurs façons
de faire on interdit dans certaines
villes dans certains états des méthodes
de force là comme le recours à des
méthodes de force comme le genou là sur
le climat sur le dos pour immobiliser
quelqu'un ce que ça pourrait être le
début du grand changement profond
souhaitez écouter c'est le souhait c'est
le souhait de tout le monde non
seulement les afro américains mais
également moi ce qui me donne de
l'espoir pour qu'il y ait un changement
justement durable pour que ce soit un
point tournant au sein de la société
américaine c'est que autres les afro
américains qui sont interpellés
directement un parent ce racisme
institutionnel mais c'est la
mobilisation de jeunes afro-américains
blanc j'ai vu des femmes faire une
barrière justement peau qu'il y ait
protection des jeunes afro-américains
donc cesser cette interpellation contre
de dire j'ai écouté le racisme c'est
aussi mon affaire c'est un problème
social auquel il faut s'attaquer
et là on sent une mobilisation et cette
charge sociale ou cette charge raciale
n'a pas à être porté uniquement par les
afro américaines vont vous voyez donc il
ya un ensemble de citoyens américains
blancs qui disent que ça suffit alors là
à mon avis je crois que ce mouvement
ouvre la porte effectivement à un
changement on espère ce changement les
afro américains réclament ce changement
depuis des décennies et je citerai un
sondage qui a été fait en 2018 par
l'université de chicago qui démontre
clairement que les afro-américains 52
ans après le décès l'assassinât de
martin luther king sentent qu'il n'y a
pas d'amélioration
donc il y avait une espèce de fossé
entre la perception des américains
blanc donc la population blanche et les
afro-américains et afro-américaine
absolument s'imposer là il est vraiment
perceptible et ça a été très vraiment
exprimé à travers ce sondage donc c'est
ça illustre à quel point les conditions
sociales les inégalités raciales les
inégalités sociales exacerbe une
situation qui a un imac sur la cohésion
sociale
on parle beaucoup des afro-américains on
va se parler un peu plus tard cet avant
midi on pourra aborder un peu la
situation ici chez nous parce que des
inégalités
il y en a vous en avez certainement été
témoin vous pourrez nous en parler mais
en terminant quelques secondes pour le
moment qu'est ce que vous espérez des
manifestations d'aujourd'hui ici à
montréal et à sherbrooke et à québec à
québec écoutez là encore si comme du
point de vue de la sociologue que je
suis de voir toute cette mobilisation
vous savez les inégalités sociales les
inégalités raciales ne se retrouve pas
uniquement aux états unis donc ce qui
interpelle la population québécoise
c'est aussi des questions de racisme qui
perdure aussi au sein de la société
québécoise
il y à aussi au québec des inégalités
sociales il ya cette inégalité raciale
que l'on retrouve dans différents
domaines
par exemple un taux de chômage beaucoup
plus élevé chez les jeunes noirs je vous
en parlerai un peu plus tard mais
également des revenus il ya une
disparité des revenus par exemple pour
les communautés noires
comparativement à la moyenne québécoise
de hockey des écoles y avait 10 des
disparités qui existent aussi au sein de
notre société québécoise et il nous faut
en prendre conscience comme société pour
également à deviennent des changements
des changements clair dans les
politiques publiques dans les programmes
qui sont mis en place pour assurer
l'égalité des droits pour tous les
citoyens du québec
on en reparlera on sait qu'il ya
une volonté en tout cas du côté du
gouvernement le go ailleurs avec
certains changements on reparle de tout
ça un peu plus tard mais là encore merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin avec
plaisir messieurs